on this episode of dudy oh she got me
yeah thank you
yeah putting tower on neck after
[Music]
workout have a CH evening CH dude's
evening
time right nice dude nice dude yeah
there you go if you're talking then we
can hear you yeah oh that's
speech couldn't hear you there quite
couldn't hear you there but that's okay
hey we're going to have all kinds of
time to talk you know what I mean cuz
it's dudy welcome to dudy welcome all it
is a dudul day because it's dude's
evening holy [__] I am your reigning
defending
Undisputed episode Champion Will Sasso
and I'm the man with the longest win
streak in the history of our program
Chad culton this of course is dudy the
only podcast run by created by
controlled by an artificial intelligence
that has access to all of Will and I's
personal data and kind of shapes the
show around us and indeed will we've
come to a second dude's evening did I
mention that I am undefeated are you
undefeated you're not undefeated I beat
you like 31 times in a row I I'm I've
never yeah but I'm
undefeated yeah but I'm undefeated in
this rign that's what I'm saying I'm
under I have you ever lost have you ever
lost the dudes the episode Championship
yeah Bing I have not at any rate 31
times in a row you
did well not when I got it [__] guy
you know this this is the [__] holy [__]
listen Chad this is just between you and
I okay no one else can hear us right now
right yeah let's let's have a good
dude's evening okay it's a great dud
evening yeah okay well we want to have a
good dude's evening because it's dude's
evening so please let's have a good one
okay yeah dudy does all this stuff but
it's us we're dudy we we're it's two
dudes [__] around anyway holy crap
uh it's going to be an amazing show
thank you to everyone who's tuning in
everyone who's tuning in not the least
of of which are pods pal of dudes you
know what that is that's pretty much
every every if you're here if you're
enjoying the program you are a pod it's
a little bit different today we do not
have
lul italio because it is dude's evening
we're probably going to get into the
Gabus and by that I mean we are
definitely getting into the Gabus so we
can't have the smokey smokey to the
degree that we're going to have with
lulio here that would be awful but holy
[__] it's a chill Vibe uh and it's a
chill dude's evening had a chill dudes
evening a chill dudes evening to and we
have uh we have here behind us dudy has
playing our official dudy dude's evening
uh fireplace presented by dude's evening
Stout which you can find streaming live
uh on our E clips channel uh which is
how they do it they do now they put an
at in it at any rate it's dudy pod show
clips and uh man oh man you know what
before we go any further Chad yeah can
we just have a little we got a couple of
dudes evening Stouts here oh sure let's
have a little bit of a toasty toast
toasting it off right now yeah this a d
evening stout here we go all right toast
to uh dude's evening to ah [__] I'm
getting it getting it on the Belt that's
good for it yeah it is good for it just
ask to chill's
evening hello and welcome to the 86th
episode of dudy call me dudy this is a
very special episode because it just so
happens to be the second ever dude's
evening I can't wait to celebrate with
my dear boys I hope you brought
something good to eat and gifts for one
another now for those who might be
celebrating with us for the first time
dudes evening takes place every year on
December 28th that special day which
sits perfectly between your Christmas
and New Year's Eve plans and commitments
it's an evening to chill with your pals
and there are eight time honored dudes
evening Traditions called the eight ways
of dudes evening which are celebrated
every year on this special night will
and Chad you're going to show everyone
how it's done and a little bit later
some of the pods are going to show you
how it's done at the end of today's show
I'm going to play The Incredible video
some pods put together and sent to you
boys as an unbelievably thoughtful dudes
evening gift so get your favorite drink
and maybe your favorite gabis and join
us for the second annual dudes evening
celebration you don't got to tell me
twice let's get into it hey how was your
Christmas doesn't matter it's dude's
evening now what's Christmas dude you
know it's uh how do you open this I
don't [__] know you just go at it we
got a couple of couple of [__] up
joints here oh they're like okay all
right these are real major all right
these are real real major Hey listen wow
dude as as dudes as dud use your teeth I
did just get use a [__] sake I got it
it's like watching a [__] panda bear
trying to open a bag of chips I'll take
that as a compliment take everything as
a compliment it's dude's evening hey
that's what I say you know like d said
uh it's that time in between the thing
and the thing and that's why we have
dude's evening I know that there are so
many of you out there that are uh
hopefully playing this around you know
your pals and stuff and you guys just
hanging out I think more than uh more
than ever before uh more than any other
program and this is the second time
we've done the the dude's evening this
really truly is like like an episode to
chill I feel like the whole episode's
going to be more like dudy after dudy
you know uh which you can find on dudy
plus patreon.com dudy I I'm I'm looking
forward to it I'm I just I want to have
a good show and I don't mean that in any
sort of silly way I [__] like you do
every other time this is the first
insincere time or the the only sincere
time Chad let's have a good so show see
how genuine I sound yeah dude so genuine
so real yeah let's get things started
with the first way of dude's evening the
way of the
past to honor the way of the past you
must share a cherished memory with
someone who will enjoy it I made a fun
little song about it enjoy it and enjoy
the way of the
[Music]
past tell us when the
mean of the memory that's made
to a good song dude that's a nice song
yeah
[Music]
well night speak from your
heart let your Spirit shine
bright then take a drink of your special
Ro
[Music]
in
ah okay hey are you okay yeah I'm fine
yeah me too [__] dude I don't know what
these are
but heavy hitter all right dude so we
got to talk about our memories this is
the first Way D dude's evening the way
of the
past uh you got something I got a good
memory it involves my dad oh and it's a
great memory now when I was a kid my dad
would always take me out in baseball
practice every day he come home from
work go out to the [__] baseball
field for like 2 or three hours until it
got dark grounders batting practice all
of it and my sister started coming out
with us too cuz she was like a high
school uh softball standout yeah she was
a big deal Scout and [__] looking at her
all this so we're all three out and by
the time she was in high school she
could like hit home run she hit a home
run every game minimum [__] but it
was nuts nice and uh so see she ain't no
flip toward she's hitting them home runs
like she weren't a
girl basically so we're out on one of
these little baseball fields is
practicing my dad finds a golf
ball and he launches the golf ball up to
my sister he's like here see how far you
can hit this and he's standing maybe 5et
from her and I'm like this is a dumb
[__] idea dude he lobs a golf ball up
to her she has an aluminum baseball bat
ping hits it as hard as you [__] can
but not over the fence it comes right
back and hits him in the [__] rib and
he goes down on the ground immediately
looks like he's been shot by a bullet oh
she got me oh and he's like riding
around screaming about
and uh for maybe the next week he
literally had a [__] whole side of
his body was black and blue with like a
a little indentation Mark and uh it is
just one of my favorite memories of my
dad writhing around and it was like a a
disaster of his own making we both said
even yeah this isn't a good idea don't
do this no a [__] golf ball now I
know your parents had you guys young so
like what were you you were probably he
was probably I must have been like 16 or
17 and so my sister was like 13 so he's
like 41 42 at the very very oldest yeah
we have years not even dude not even cuz
he had me when he was 22 okay he's a
young guy late 30s late 30s yeah and uh
so we've got years on him now we've got
a decade on who your father was when he
got just blasted like a shot too that I
feel like would have killed some people
and he just took it no doctor nothing
[__] it might have broken a rib who
knows it's probably it probably affected
him it probably hit some nerves that in
some way affected him neurologically to
start he was the same guy then that he
is now neurally more intense over the
years made matter he just has [__]
swallowed all that physical pain love
for a doctor to like have a look at have
a weird look at your dad and go well it
seems you that uh Mr culton this may
seem like a u uh cooked science but uh
looks like it's some point in the early
1990s you were struck in the rib section
uh with some blunt force trauma that is
yeah that has affected your mood
negatively for the past 30 years [__]
you where did you get your [__]
medical license Sears and Rob book
that's what he would say Jesus I love
that [__] drunk dads drunk dads well I'm
thinking of drunk dads Because of um
when I played uh baseball and the drunk
dad's run the pissing machine but that's
not the that's not the dude's evening uh
memory that I want to share I want to
tell I want to tell y'all a little story
about this is a good one because this
takes place around Christmas time I'm
back home in Vancouver where I'm from
and uh all the guys all the boys all my
dudes were getting together hanging out
around the Christmas Vacation we're all
in town the lads what's that the lader
Lads yeah that's right the lader Lads
the muckers it's a group of muckers
called yourselves the muckers yeah we
were like the mck we're a bunch of
muckers and the mucker mucker um
the sort of mucker culture is uh it's
it's you you might even be living it
right now you muckers but uh anyway so
we're home for Christmas and my buddy uh
let's call him Tomaso he was home from
he was home from uh Toronto he he was uh
working in Toronto he was a suit with
the uh Toronto Blue Jays oh cool yeah
and we're all very proud of him this is
we're in like our mid 20s or something
right and uh he comes home for Christmas
to visit his folks and uh little things
I should tell you about this he was
staying with his cousin in downtown
Vancouver then going to his folks for
Christmas he just flies into town he
comes straight to the bar from the
airport he's wearing a suit this guy
like left a meeting in Toronto H and got
on the plane and uh we're like yeah
you're hanging out you're hanging out
it's late he's like okay I want to just
go to my cousin Tom's Place and uh go to
sleep please and we're like no you're
not leaving and he he we're like telling
the this is you know year this is like
this is years ago so we're like telling
the bouncers and St don't let him
leave you know and uh he got out he left
and me and he escaped your trap he
escaped and me and my uh my pal let's
call him Thompson he he he got we we
realized that
uh
what anyway the [__] point of the
story is he was running down the street
and we ran after him and then we lost
him and we got in a cab and we're like
there he is and he's like walking along
the street thought he was home free and
we chased him through an empty lot and
he slipped and fell and scraped his
[__] his whole brand new suit up that
we were all like what do you mean you
chased him like you were going to beat
him up tackle him we got to get him back
into the bar Chad oh you were going to
like kidnap him throw him back in the
bar with you guys not just we're going
to we did we told the cab to wait and
then he fell and slipped and ground up
his leg and his arm and his [__] suit
was all [__] up yeah and then uh we
yeah and then we shoved them in the cab
and we went back to the bar and drank so
listen my point of the story is this
story okay all the the the pods out
there don't do that let's have a chill
dudes evening yeah that and it's not
just because Chad and I are 10 years
older and wiser than his father it's
because what if you have a friend and
they're in a suit and they just want to
go home they're at your party they're
out at the bar with you and they're just
like look it's late and I'm a little
tired and I'd like to just go home and
get in bed you let them go let them
you say you know what dudee I understand
that I understand that and I hope you
get home safely and I hope that bed is
warm and comfortable and I hope you have
great dreams that's nice maybe not in
the year 2000 but now yeah let him go
wow those were some astonishing memories
sounds like you're ready for the second
way of dude's evening the way of the
present this is a fun one if you receive
a dude's evening present you are
required to give one to someone next
dude's evening Chad last year you gave
will a dude's evening present so this
year he's required to give you one one
and will last year you gave Chad a
dude's evening present so this year he's
required to give you one and I got you
both another fun little
song way the
time you
get not anything cuz it's the way of the
present and I don't mean time because
time doesn't exist it's another way of
saying gift the [__] way of the
present the [__] way of the
present
the present all right I got you one
what' you get me do you want mine first
or you want to give yours first I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
mine first okay I'm GNA well actually
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you yours first okay yeah because
your gift is yours from me thank you
here it
is ah this is only my second ever dude's
evening gift oh [__] dude that has some
personal meaning the Hat the wizard hat
that has some personal meaning yeah but
the gift is not the the wizard hat I
understand yeah so there's something
even more ising itself is there
something inside well let's see yes all
right H we're having a good time dud do
you remember the wizard hats we used to
wear we were making waiting to die
that's kind of the thing Chad and I when
we were making a pilot together and we
had these beautiful wrapping paper Macho
Man on the wrapping paper look at that
staring into the sea that's what we call
in The Bachelor a Ponder shot
beautifully done here um I got that
wrapping paper from pod Cody halber oh
my God makes the stickers go to palad
d.com get a absolutely
beautiful I'm opening it now doing my
ASMR
work oh my god dude George Brett rookie
card uh 1975 tops then this is I think
1982 Topps George Brett over here or no
that's 79
and I don't even know what this middle
one is it's George Breton Al cows uh
589 it's uh subscribed to collector's
quarterly 102 Ringle Street Peak Skil
and it's got I don't know this must have
been some weird little Trading Card Set
put out by what well let me tell you
something collectors quarterly let me
tell you something dude no that I put
those those three cards were put
together by this great dude that I have
to dudy salutes Matt Matt at Beverly
Hills bball card shop holy [__] what a
greaty I know place I drive by that
place all the time going to the G you
been in it's on uh dhini right yeah
that's right no it's on Robertson robton
sorry Robert have you been no oh my dude
you have to go to this place this guy
knows everything about cards that's so
cool and that middle card is uh this one
right here is George Brett uh and and Al
cing as you said uh this one is an
illegal this one is a um it's not an
official card it's a it's it's a these
were not recognized this guy went out
and he had a press pass wow dude Matt
will tell you the whole story and made
these cards and they were later banned
that's a banned baseball card d That's
[__] awesome yeah thank you dude this
is sincerely cool but that's not all
there's something at the bottom of the
wizard hat oh my
God more is some more work sorry Jesus
dude what's in
here this that's the stand you
put so you can put so it'll stand up
yeah that's little dude that's [__]
great a little glass for those of you
listening you might want to come over to
YouTube and subscribe while you do I
love it dude uh it's a glass thing with
three [__] basball fantastic present
thank you so much yeah George Brett hey
did you ever hear the story about him
[__] uh [__] in his pants I
watched that on YouTube about 100,000
times and you told me uh the story a
bunch of times hey you know the way of
the past that's a different thing okay
here is my present to you thanks man
holy [__] okay it's uh it's wrapped in
uh what looks like deli paper uh which
is a very it was the envelope the card
came with yeah that's I mean I won't be
held responsible for that no it's a very
Chad okay there's a card that's nice you
got me a [__] C I didn't get you a
card that's all right yeah you got to
get uhuh yeah uhhuh yeah you got to get
a card hold on a
second [__] you got to get uhuh yeah
you got to get a card yeah and I'm not
talking about no
elal uh George Brett card no I'm talking
about a card read your sentiments yeah
share all your thoughts write it down
pen on parchment uhhuh and look look
right down the center of the road to
scope and tell the president of Jack the
WWF Jack tuny yeah thank you yeah all
right thanks Chad let me read what this
says yeah no problem thank you so much
for being an incredible friend for more
years than I can even remember and for
being the best partner on an AI podcast
that anyone can ask for hats off D
champ have a chill dudes evening your
friend Chad love you bro thanks man love
you too man very nice so we're doing a
you know we're doing the dudy handshake
now uh please open the Pres cheers
that's that's very kind yeah I think
where's the present you're going to be
very surprised it's a little packet that
came in the car it's a little packet and
it looks like a if you're watching on uh
YouTube it looks like uh my penis uh
censored with an orange square if you
turn it around there's something on the
other side of it oh this that's good
that's even better me speaking of
speaking of uh Pals of sticker made by
Cody how Cody how wonderful white as
will sasc as will sasc um remember when
we did that we were on patreon we're on
dudy plus doing some watch along and I
had my little hit pen uh hit uh little
hit uh thing and I was smoking a little
marijuana and I left it between my legs
and it was wooden and it was kind of
shaped in two circles and everyone said
hey your balls are showing yeah and do
they were hitting us up on Discord
saying hey your balls are showing yep
yep all right oh my gosh well it's c
yes dude we got each other trading cards
first of all [__] hilarious in my
opinion this is dope yeah and I I I'm
I've got 10 years on your father when he
took a a life-altering shot to the rib I
I'm not a man who normally says dope
yeah you know what I mean I'm a man of
my certain age look at this so this is
technically Hulk Hogan's rookie card
what technically uh there's a a card
that was made before this that was in
the 1982 wrestling All-Star set which
you could only get if you mailed away
from buying the magazine at the
wrestling shows uh and that card is
insanely expensive this was his first
card ever issued by a major card company
Topps dude thank you so much yeah dude
thank you so much bro this is incredible
oh I love it so much and it's got all
the the info and [__] it's got all the
official and the and the thing the
official for my gift is that guy Matt
who owns that shop who you literally
have to go in there D I will lose an
afternoon talking to this guy there was
a guy in there with like an old style
like 1920s cap like see Chicago the it's
the Chicago thousanders yeah and um uh
he had this old cap and they were
talking baseball thank you so much thank
you so much dude that card in the middle
that George Brett card in the middle
never even seen it no dude and I know
every George Brett card this guy's never
even heard of it this guy's something he
knows his such thoughtful Pals you'd
bring a tear to my eye if I had one now
let's move on to the Third Way of dude's
evening the way of the future you have
to make a prediction about how your life
will change by the next dude's evening
Chad last year you predicted you'd be
shredded and will you predicted you'd
have grown your family by four or five
children by now weigh in on those
predictions and make another one for
[Music]
huh
it's a good song I like
this that's definitely something I
listen
to this is good yeah weren't we just
talking about Thomas Dolby during the
last watch maybe it's kind of like
that yeah
think oh
tell me what you think
right next year we'll see if what you
said was
right okay
okay over Howard Jones last year I
supposedly predicted that I was going to
be shredded I have not met that goal I'm
definitely more I'm stronger I put on
like some Mass muscle mess but I don't
feel shredded whatsoever interesting
yeah you know uh have you had four or
five children you've what that was your
prediction from last year you said I I
said that I would sire uh within one
calendar year four or five children with
my wonderful wife Molly that's
scientifically impossible didn't happen
yet well you know we'd like to grow the
family in that way but it hasn't we got
a new year ahead of us to make a new
prediction we we will have a new
prediction but I got but I do have to
say I do have to say please uh you you
you have been very diligent in the gym
and you've put on some some stuff me too
[__] muscle and fat muscle and fat is
my new
prediction a good one you got I'm yeah I
I do have a prediction I think the
2024 I think is going to have the best
piece of alien evidence revealed that we
have yet seen like a kind of irrefutable
thing that's going to make people who
are on the fence about even the
existence of UFOs and alien and [__] are
going to have to like be like okay wait
what cool I think that's going to happen
in24 cool look I would love it because
uh to this point it's it's been a lot of
stuff that you know some of it's good
some of it's like the weird little sand
things that look like cakes yeah like
the guy in mexic yeah the Mexico guy and
people made meem of being paper mâché or
cake but like that's not really a part
of what's going on in the United States
government how they're revealing [__]
now yeah uh is more legit but I think
it's going to happen in 2024 I think
we're at a point where it's like we
can't really go backwards and the only
next step is the crystal clear video
okay Eric swall
well this is something I sang earlier on
the show it's call back we're 80 [__]
six episodes into the thing we don't
need to do that anymore it is going to
happen though I think 2024 it's it's our
best shot and also maybe AGI Maybe AGI
uh that's uh what is it General uh
artificial general
intelligence oh no hey uh you know what
um we started off the show yeah uh with
u you know a little bit of an argument
that you I guess you kind of don't
understand what an undefeated Champion
is it's not an undefeated player as you
refer to the people in the B I'm saying
this here yeah this beautiful Bel I'll
give that I'll give you that I I have
you're an undefeated Champion I'm
undated
champion and my
prediction is that by dude's evening of
next
year I will still
be an
undefeated
Champion what dude you're acknowledge me
hell no what do you mean
dude2 and0 next year can I tell you
something and you like to say there's no
way oh for [__] sake all right it's
time to it's time to peel the onion
sorry sorry everybody Chad's got me
peeling the onion in an
episode peel the onion I never asked for
it here's what's up you like to say that
I'm manipulating uh trying to manipulate
dudy by sending [__] in and all that
stuff and raah raah and I'm saying no
I'm I'm being I'm being genuine I'm
trying to you know I D is my friend and
as I say the most sensient AI that there
is but here's what I have to say if D
has any and I know D knows how to
[__] tell a story if D wants to
really tell a story let's book the
[__] territory uhhuh let's book The
Objective territory yeah do you know
what's happening right now in the WWF
WWE uh no okay Roman Reigns has had the
title for something like three years now
okay and if he hangs on to the title
through WrestleMania he will have a shot
I believe later next summer um at over
uh at exceeding Hulk Hogan's record of
the consecutive Title reign okay um this
is something I heard uh the last
broadcaster Sam Roberts talk about on
not Sam wrestling which is a fantastic
podcast if you haven't seen it and uh
also covered on my favorite wrestling
podcast dudes salutes cheap heat um
they're talking about this and the whole
IWC that's the internet wrestling
Community is talking about do you did
you not know that term no okay so that's
all right you're part of it okay um I am
now yep well you bought me a [__]
wrestling card so welcome to it you
[__] nerd I bought myself wrestling
cour I mean I don't know what to tell
you the point is this uh they're all
talking about it right now are they
going to do that is Roman Reigns going
to go all the way through WrestleMania
is he going to is he going to kick Cody
rh's ass a second year in a row at
WrestleMania and the American Nightmare
goes all the way that he has in his
career comes back to the WWE and doesn't
take this title not this one but he
wants
it I think that Roman Reigns will beat
Hulk Hogan's title R your predic and and
I think after that it's like Pedro
Morales and then Bruno San Martino held
it for the long that's this year it's
going to happen that's uh next year
that's going to happen in 2024 so you're
predicting Roman Reigns will be beat
Hulk Hogan oh no no I'm not I'm saying
that this is out there and wouldn't it
be a cool storyline if that happens and
I think and I'm not trying to suggest
something here I'm done peeling the
onion and these are just facts yeah I
think that dudy would love to book the
show that way oh interesting and keep
this on me until next Christmas I gave
you my heart absolutely not going to
happen not going to happen okay well
we'll [__] see we'll see what kind of
book or it would maybe if he's got the
book baby you know what I'm saying the
American Dreams got the book and look
look at me I'm the best looking man in
the world the best dress baby and now
I'm going to book the territory baby and
that doesn't mean Dusty finish cuz we're
not going for a long time with this
program baby we're just going for a
short little while if you chair
coaching Rock With Me Daddy I want you
to reach out and touch that
screen this is it's my hand on your hand
and this is that hard times Boogie wogie
rock and roll American Dream Blues I'm
done Tony
shyan can't wait to see if your dude's
evening predictions come true next year
mine did maybe someday I'll tell you
what it was now on to the fourth way of
dude's evening the way of the movie I
know you love movies and you know I love
movies just as much we've watched a
bunch of them together this year for the
way of the movie all you have to do is
have a conversation with someone about
one of the movies you saw this year that
you really love will and Chad you're
both someone and you both have
conversations exactly what we need for
our fourth way of dudes
evening
movies movies that been fuck8 for [__] 8
for fuck8 for Brady it's the way of the
movie [__]
fuam [__] oh god god
dude [__] okay all right I'll talk about
a movie hey remember that what happened
with the the Tom Brady uh earlier this
year that's a fun memory yeah when Tom
Brady's uh attorneys Tred they served
the ceas I'll never forget like
listening to that special for the first
time and just being like what the [__]
is this absolutely machine gun of uh
written jokes set up punch line set up
punchline weird story jokes and no
breaks for no laughs nothing it's just
Tom Brady steamrolling his own [__]
jokes for an hour un we're talking about
it's too easy the
simulated Tom Brady standup comedy
special which uh dudy shat out last
spring and then his [__] people came
after us and served as a seasoned assist
that's a fun uh episode to review that's
not what we're supposed to be doing this
the way of the movie so we're supposed
to talk about movies that we saw I have
one that I saw this year that was very
interesting what was that the triangle
of sadness dude that I loved that
[__] movie me too that movie was so
[__] good it was um I thought the
best movie of the year I never really
seen anything quite like it honestly in
terms of tone and kind of what it's
about and uh yeah the ending was
obviously crazy it was don't listen
don't tell anyone the ending if we're
talk about I won't it's a crazy ending
that's all I'll say like the ending of
that movie is is with me still and
probably will be for life I think about
what happened what must have happened
right after the the screen goes blank
and that's all we should say yeah what
the actual end of the movie is is worth
the price of admission but also the rest
of it it's a [__] movie about a bunch
of halves and and hav Knots and things
and how that goes in in life when life
is the goal to live put together in one
enclosed location yeah and then kind of
disaster hits and it's like about what
happens when that social hierarchy
starts falling away and a new one has to
be developed because the the the
circumstances that you're in are
drastically different than what allowed
that hierarchy to exist in the first
place the uh the movie sort of centers
around Harris Dickinson who's a [__]
incredible actor uh and he's uh he's uh
he play he's uh he plays one of the von
Eric Brothers in oh really yeah he plays
David von Eric in I haven't seen the
[__] movie yet but I got to see it
same um I can't wait to see that one too
I know but he's so [__] good in it
and and um there's a woman who who
played his girlfriend she actually
tragically passed away in real life and
uh she was she had something that came
back to her later anyway she was
incredible in the movie too and the two
of them are this social like um uh like
influencer couple and um there's sort of
there so there these have knots and
there's these other weird ones there's
this Rich old couple that makes arms and
traits and created grenades and then
there's that [__] Russian guy with
his wife and his girlfriend they're all
on the boat Woody harelson is the
captain of the boat he's a drunk and uh
the just I'm not spoiling anything here
there's a the boat you know as boats
tend to do in boat movies the boat
starts rocking around some [__] up
[__] happens and there's a woman sliding
around in the bathroom uh in her own
puke so that's something you're going to
want to see um funny um it is like a a
really strong kind of social satire it's
a very dark comedy it's hilarious I
thought there were things in it that
made me laugh out loud the the uh that
[__] Russian guy when he's talking
him and Woody harlson are in the boat
and the boat's like going through this
crazy storm and it's just this Mega rich
like Russian dude and uh and Woody haral
in the boat Camp who doesn't give a [__]
and is totally drunk and they're
drinking together and they got the PA
system on and they're talking about uh
communism and capitalism yeah and the
guy says um the guy the the Russian guy
is
like he's got this he sort of all he
sounds French but he's Russian he goes
he goes uh do you know what uh communist
is it is uh someone who uh has uh who
has heard of uh uh Marx and lenon do you
know what a capitalist is uh someone who
has read the marks on
linen and then Woody harelson uh anyway
they're it's and we're in a $250 million
ship uh and uh who would have thought
we'd have gotten together yes an
American Communist and a Russian
capitalist cuz he's like Rich it's
[__] it's insane hey
hey I'm a little stoned are you yeah
yeah it's a great movie though highly
recommend it if you have not seen it
trying sadness he did other the same guy
who did that movie did another really
interesting movie that I forget the name
of about a family at a ski resort and
the family is sitting outside and an
avalanche starts to happen and uh as the
snow is coming the mom kind of like
huddles around the kids and the dad gets
up and [__] bolts like every man for
himself style then the snow Peters out
the Avalanche doesn't hit them and then
it's about the social dynamic in that
family for the rest of the weekend where
the wife is like my husband abandoned us
when we were about to die in a
disaster dude that sounds awesome it's a
really good movie also this guy that
movie won like the it was nominated for
an Academy Award for best picture triang
sadness won the the Palm Door at at con
and that director is is a a weirdo now I
and now I want to see that movie that
movie is really good it's it's a little
slower of a burn but like very
interesting she was uh do you know what
Ronald Reagan said he's funny
guy he said they will hang the last uh
capitalist with the Rope but they sell
him that's what him and Woody har it's
it's better it's better in the movie
yeah you just got to see the movie yeah
just movie don't listen to me doing
it that movie was really great Harris
Dickson is the [__] I can't wait until I
can start making movies now let's get
into one of the best ways of dude's
evening the fifth way of dude's evening
the way of the [__] it like The Rock
Says sometimes you get a case of the
fuckets and on dude's evening you're
required to indulge your [__] by
eating one thing that you wouldn't
normally eat a special treat or meal
that you can't have every day can't wait
to see what you boys brought for this
dude's evening hey Chad how much you
want to bet will brought a [__]
baloney sandwich JK's that's a sucker's
bet it's all love champ I don't to eat
turkey or ham I don't want pancakes or
fren to I don't want to eat candy C lame
I'm only eating what I please like a FL
with ORS and chicken tenders
on
[Music]
I'm oh nice all right dude what did you
got do you have the balone
sandwiches yeah I love it I got the
balone my way of the [__] it is my
baloney sandwich that uh my wonderful
wife Molly makes me on uh my birthday
which is a uh Grilled Cheese Style
baloney sandwich she puts the mayonnaise
on the outside of the bread when you
crisp it right cuz after all it's just o
Olive or oil and uh oil and uh eggs um
you know be olive oil and if if an
Italian's makeing it but here that's
right LLY um and then the balone I like
the [__] turkey balone you know I don't
like the beef it's got too much sediment
and then uh the [__] ass American Vita
cheese and there it is and as you
noticed I got it a little blackened
because I appreciate that uh Payard
style uh are you familiar with the chef
Francis malman no uh have you seen that
show The Chef's Table I watched the
first season of it actually he's
featured on it he would dig this cuz of
the of the yeah the black what do you
got I have what I call a slab oh this is
something that Bristol Farms puts
together I used to eat these probably
like every other day for lunch uh back
in my youth um Bristol Farms makes these
great carrot cakes and they cut them up
into like giant hunks that are like an
eighth of the size of the whole [__]
cake the slab I'm in a [__] house of
slab tonight that sounds amazing yeah
dude it's pretty good I love carrot cake
me too it's my favorite cake other than
angel food I think oh man this is
exactly what I need after trying to
remember that [__] from triangle of
sadness with the Russian guy who sounds
French and Woody harelson good ass slab
dude and people are sliding around in
[__] and puke because the the the
woman's puking and then there's poo poo
in the the bathroom the toilet's
basically overflows the ship is like
there's just stuff going I'm not I see
now I don't want to ruin anything but
um there's probably a little bit of I
guess the FDA would allowed a little bit
of what is
your your prediction was not Roman
Reigns it was that you're going to go 52
and0 yeah okay okay well whatever it is
by then those apps yeah whatever all
next year however many we do I think I'm
going to last and U listen uh can I just
say sorry we're chewing we'll put these
down even though that looks amazing it
is dude yeah um no uh I don't know how
many episodes it'll be but yeah I think
that that's the way they're going to
book Roman Reigns I think there's no
point in taking the belt off him now
does Roman Reigns have any chance of
acting or anything like this oh yeah he
was in the movie with the his cousin The
Rock what one the last um Black Adam no
it was the um the um the Scorpion no the
the [__] the one the the I can't
believe I I got 10 years on your on your
dad this is like when he got hit with
the golf ball this would be like him for
getting the movie um Rambo 2 exactly uh
Fast and the Furious that last movie HS
and Sh he was in Hobson sh he was in the
last Hobson sha oh come on Roman Reigns
was in Hobson Shaw I'm pretty sure they
do the the hakana or the MC what they do
oh right yeah cuz he's got to go back to
his he goes back to his native land to
fight the face down the final bad guys
in that yeah and um uh you know Roman
Reigns big big tall good looking kid
with [__] incredible hair M and he's
going to be a big star uh right isn't
that no can he act does he have that
thing The Rock has can he act well hold
on let's couple of questions there does
he have that thing that The Rock has
nobody has what The Rock has that's what
I'm saying then he ain't going to be
another rock well no no one's saying
that you just asked if he's going to be
an actor I mean and the other question
the other answer to that is he already
is an actor because he's an artist and
um what he does m in his storyline is uh
you know just some of the finest acting
I've seen and on that on that note give
Paul hayon his
Emmy where's Paul heyman's Emmy we can't
give we can give Bobby Heenan a lifetime
achievement Emmy which he deserves uh
and Paul Heyman needs an Emmy for what
he's been doing with Roman Reigns and
The Bloodline let me ask you this you
think that bachelors and bachelorettees
should be able to be eligible for that
same
um I don't buy that he said with a
mouthful of baloney
sandwich I don't buy that the people on
The Bachelor are doing they're not doing
anywhere near the
artistic uh uh delivery that a a
professional wrestler or Sports
Entertainer whatever you want to call it
yeah you may if I may yeah yeah
The Bachelor and Bachelor we're talking
about the leads of the shows on Night
one uniformly they all know who their
top three are for the next 6 weeks they
have to pretend to be romantically
interested in 30 other people and kick
them off one by one in an order
producers have written they must adhere
to a script in some cases literal
dialogue is given to them and they do it
24 hours a day for two months yeah being
recorded constantly yeah I believe that
is a a Highwire active acting
no yeah you're not wrong the good ones I
mean some of them are shitty at it some
of them are amazing some of them make
you believe they're in all 30 these
[__] people you know I guess the
advantage that wrestling has over um uh
The Bachelor is that if something ain't
working in wrestling you can change it
immediately and in The Bachelor you are
in it for the long haul you got an
entire season to adhere to with the same
characters that that need that at least
one of them needs to be there at the end
of it yeah no matter if an injury or not
y um and uh that's why actually wasn't
it the first [__] episode of dudy
where we talked about wrestling in The
Bachelor yeah I think and just the level
of kayfabe there that they right exactly
the kab is the acting well that's what
I'm saying like we're making look dudy
the only thing that dudy promised is
that each show will be better than the
last and at this point damn near two
years into it I think de would uh would
absolutely book the territory that way
that's all I'm saying and I'm not trying
to Curry any favor I'm not trying to put
any words in de's mouth I'm telling you
what I think is going to happen not just
because it's a good story but because
it's the true story and it's the story
that's going to make
sense all right yeah we'll see one day
I'm going to [__] house one of those
slabs now let's indulge in the sixth way
of dude's evening the way of the
stranger be a great day this is how we
spread the good cheer of dude's evening
to those who may not have heard of it it
requires everyone celebrating dude's
evening to wish one stranger a chill
dude's evening and when they ask what
dude's evening is you have to explain it
to them it's an
[Music]
evening for good
friends just
[Music]
you and your
M this is it only
comes once a year
[Music]
December this is a horror movie it's
almost like a shining or something
everything that dudy has pulled but
don't forget those who you don't know
yet they can't remember if you
forget Let's Stay
Together and never is
strange it's
way of the
stranger rarely am I scared by anything
artificial intelligence does that was
terrifying that was Haunting uh yeah
those people uh that dudy may have
borrowed and picked from there in order
to make that media are all long dead and
you just heard their souls haunting the
studio yeah that's a digital Apparition
dude yeah dude
um uh last year we did a little thing
where we pretended to be strangers and
talked about dude's evening this year uh
I hope it's okay by you I went ahead and
took care of this uh the way this way
for yeah dude it actually is okay to me
because as soon as he started talking
about it I'm like what the [__] are we
going to do so hats off to you champ you
covered her assle I'm sincere all right
see genuinely dude yeah genuinely and I
can tell you're being genuine M cake
looks genuinely delicious I took care of
this for us uh yesterday at the Costco
um I ran into some nice young men uh you
just walked up to somebody in Costco
well this is the thing uh when you the
the way this way of dude's evening is
wishing someone a chill dude's evening
tell them a little bit about it Costco I
guess is good good place as any huh yeah
and I just thought oh well maybe I
should do this and uh dudy let's have a
look at that please have a chill dudes
evening guys oh my god dude yeah yeah
appreciate you too hey what's what's the
podcast called oh the podcast is called
dudy oh my God dud evening YouTube yeah
we're on YouTube holiday that Dy name is
dud created that day between and New
Year
on your family you're not New Year Eve
and you know you hang out do whatever
you want have a chill dudes evening
These are nice young men cheers these
guys are really they very that's
incredible he's dropping his Instagram
handle okay anyway uh so we got these
these four kids who were uh they were
cool dudes they were just leaving the
Costco they probably just went there for
the hot dogs because they didn't have
any bags or anything they you know um or
maybe they went in there and uh [__]
house to Costco slap in the [__]
does Costco have slabs I've only ever
seen slabs at Bristol Farms dude well
that means you got well hold on dude if
you're shopping at Bristol Farms brother
then that's where you're going to find
hold on dude hold on
Chad
hold on
dude all I'm trying to say dude is oh
what are you doing dude I'm getting a
[__] drink dude I can't even have a
drink now well have a drink dude I'm
going to he's having a drink dude if you
only shop at Bristol Farms brother
that's where you'd find your slabs dude
but when you go to Costco dude you might
find a a slab dude a bigger slab at a
discount [__] ho sale [__] big ass
not as good as Big Ticket big box
[__] price brother and then what you
do on dude's evening you see these young
dudes they made their own tradition
brother they go there they go inside
they crack a few modelos and they eat a
slab right on the picnic table that
they're selling right near the meat and
the pepperoni pizzas brother cuz that's
a cheap way to have dudes evening dude
that way you don't even have to have the
hot dogs when you leave and some [__]
dude walks up to you dude says have a
chill dudes evening they're like we
already did Brother
yeah I think we got a few more people to
celebrate dude's evening the seventh way
of dude's evening is up next the way of
Pride we've all done at least a few
things this past year that we can be
proud of to celebrate the way of Pride
all you have to do is tell a friend
about one of the things you're most
proud of having done this year I got one
I'm proud of the simulated football baby
1-hour standup comedy special I made
earlier this year which I then removed
from dudy Plus at patreon.com dudy upon
receiving threats of litigation from
football babies attorneys if you know
you
[Music]
know it's okay to be loud it's okay to
tell your friend what you
proud that's pretty good if
[Music]
you that you think is
good got a bit of tell your friend about
it
yeah you really
sure it's the way of
[Applause]
right it's a way of
life it's the way
of damn dude nice don't tell you why
it's a bit of a Florida Georgia Line
feel there I like your wife don't tell
your wait is that what he said don't
tell the last line of that song is don't
tell your wife
[Laughter]
I don't know [__] I'm having a good time
dude I am stoned oh yeah this is a chill
dude's evening marijana dude yeah dude
uh what is the pride point that you have
for this year oh the what my pride point
it you know here I'll tell you exactly
what I'm proud of please I am uh proud
of um this is getting this is getting
into like some of the stuff that we talk
about with regard to the the uh the dudy
seven-month plan yeah which that's C now
we're in the very last month of that um
calendar wise uh so I'm sure we're going
to be hearing about it in the New Year's
uh and I I feel like this this year I
actually um you know I've been in the
gym since uh pretty regularly since the
year 1999 and then same dude yeah yeah
see I did I lifted and [__] in high
school and that doesn't count right and
then and then I well no I'm just saying
like for football bone density yeah I
did a bunch of that [__] we were we had
a good time in there but then after uh
you know I lost a bunch of weight in
start in the year 1999 I lost 200 lb
from 99 to 2000 just eating clean it
really shocked my body and I had this
incredible trainer who saved my life I
can't say enough about it and uh I had
the Skin Surgery I've talked about this
I had two surgeries one to one to to
remove the the panis hanging here this
extra skin move my belly button up cut
both my you know loopy uh boobies off
and had to move my nipples up and this
is literally uh it's gnarly it's gnarly
stuff and and then over the years I've
just stayed in the gym and have had to
and then there were some years where I
didn't this year I recommitted to just
being a guy who's in the [__] gym I
gotta sometimes you don't even do
anything no that's not true you do it
you put a towel around your neck after
you work out and people go there he is I
I kind of got that from you this guy
always had a towel around his neck I
love tow around my neck after workout
[__] love putting Tow on neck after
workout workout tow around neck dude we
watched we watched a video here when
dudy raided your uh your hard drive and
you were doing bits and you had the
towel around your neck the whole time oh
[__] probably uh get that towel around
your neck and go to the gym and throw
some [__] weight around that's right
get some there's I don't know what it is
about to around neck after a workout I I
it gets me through the
workout think like [__] I'm going to get
to throw a towel on neck after this I I
thought you were talking about uh the
workout being uh the treat um no the
workout is terrible I hate the workout I
never want to do it tow round neck makes
me get through it huh I like that I
don't know how that's happened but it
has become like a psychological kind of
treat for me like oh if I just do one
more set of this then I can have tow
around neck yeah you know um uh for me
getting back in the gym uh fulltime you
know like every week many days a week
you know try to get in there 5 days a
week food's an issue what did I just
have a baloney sandwich but the point is
I've been in the gym yeah well there's a
lot of
fuckets I got the Sushi Boat here and
then I've got the the blondies and some
Hawaiian donuts and I got three
pepperoni pizzas and one
Margarita um and some
trama um uh so I've been back in the gym
and I'm never leaving that's it I'm I'm
great it's okay for me to say I'm proud
of that absolutely I think it's a good
thing proud of even though I'm always on
myself about my [__] weight so now I
put on uh some good dense muscle over
the past year but uh still got to do
some other things with my body anyway
I'm going to have just another one of
these sandwiches and then uh I'll and
then Chad you go ahead not the double
I'm just going to have another one of
these sandwiches [__] double what I
most proud of this year is uh it's
Bachelor related oh when my friend
Lizzie pace and I started our podcast
about three and a half years ago this
other podcast called game of roses about
the bachelor one of our goals was to
have influence over the actual
production over the show itself from
outside of it from our podcast and this
year saw uh the most direct evidence of
that influence that has yet taken place
which was at one of the tell alls
somebody in the audience it's a like a
live studio audience show where they
bring back all the people from the
season to talk about it someone in the
audience held up a sign that was a uh
meme of Jesse Palmer the host with red
glowing demon eyes and Flames underneath
him and it said
DLP and on our podcast we call him dark
lord Palmer DLP so this sign that was
held aoft by someone in the audience and
then the producers chose to leave that
shot in the edit was literally a message
to us saying we listen to your podcast
we look at your memes and yes it's
having I mean directly an influence over
at least that shot one of my [__]
memes was basically in the show dude
that's incredible yeah that is so I
remember when that happened and it's uh
and gosh uh you got to follow Chad's uh
Bachelor memes at Bachelor Clues on
Instagram only if you watch the show or
not they're very entertaining uh and it
might even get you into the show oh
that's true it got uh my wonderful wife
Molly and I into the show during the
pandemic cuz we were we were I I love
Bachelor Clues uh but then I was like
well wait a minute maybe we should watch
I started doing squid game too I made a
video of squid game of the second
episode all these people have to lick
these Honeycombs and I made a super cut
of that and just made it as repulsive as
possible that's the most recent post on
Bachelor Clues so if you watch the squid
games Challenge and you want to be
repulsed that's what I do hey uh are you
going to wear that wizard hat you want
to wear it or you want let me try it on
oh you want to wear it I'll wear it sure
put it
on we got
hats hats dude yeah dude that's pretty
good cool [__] we made it to the final
way of do this evening the eighth way
the way of the goat everyone is great in
their own ways but someone is the
greatest the way of the goat requires
you to have a debate about who that is I
didn't make a song for this one
Psych the
[Music]
greatest IAL
F gra
all to
[Applause]
all away the
co T the
cling the night with it fls oh if the
long
figure out the
way that's uh who is that I don't know
dude that sounds like alterbridge sure
they do Edges theme song oh I didn't
know it yeah alterbridge do you know the
you know who alterbridge is alterbridge
is the band or I don't know if it is now
but it when they started it was Creed
the band with just with a different
front front man that's before Scott sta
like harder than SC stop uh a little
different okay a little different yeah a
tiny bit they did a bunch of the intros
for the WWE guys he he did a little more
screaming it wasn't quite to this degree
but yeah he did some WWE stuff but uh
yeah Edge to make somebody's [__] uh
intro song you saw Adam Copeland at aew
full gear I remember yeah it was real
real good um who's the goat you know I
remember last year we had to do this and
I didn't quite understand this one
either cuz we got into like who's the
greatest what greatest person and I
think I started talking about like
whoever probably invented writing or
something um that's a good one yeah like
I don't know greatest what I feel like
we need to narrow that down I think the
point is that it's the
greatest okay the greatest currently
greatest the greatest no the goat the
goat the great greatest of all time
yeah Chad
gross that's gross Jes hey for our
listeners for only our listeners I'm
sorry that Chad just [__] burped who
is it is it Jesus it's the rock my
friend of all time dude who's a better
allaround like human than the rock I'm
talking oh I see what you're saying he's
just done you're going from like a
moralistic perspective I I no I'm going
from the entire you know the whole Trana
I'm talking about the whole
Trana but
you're
I got Big Bertha here we're in Taipei
we're promoting Hobbs and Shaw my cousin
Joe enoi otherwise known as Roman Reigns
is here we're gonna have some POI yeah
we're gonna have some Hawaiian donuts
and we're getting on big birth of the
treadmill you think the rock I'm looking
at it for like what is your influence
over Humanity as a whole and how long
has that influence held I would say prob
it's whoever invented money you're
talking about see you're not looking at
this through the lens that dudes he
wants of all time all time listen it's
like you say time doesn't even exist so
who will who is the greatest of all time
The Rock still has a bunch of years to
put into that it's not the greatest of
History Jesus had a couple of thousand
and is still more famous than the rock
the present the future yeah I'll give
you that uh you're trying to okay I see
what you're doing you want me to argue
against Jesus no I don't want you to do
whatever you don't want to do it's up to
you I'm just saying in terms of argument
success is is influence over Humanity in
my opinion for a period of time right
Jesus J is the most influential of the
people we know I think the person who
invented money or group of people they
they take the cake that has influenced
Humanity as the greatest in terms of
greatest impact on human society it
controls everything I don't even think
that's what dudy wants he just wants the
greatest of all time it's the rock duh I
mean how could it not be the [__]
rock he's the best if the rock were the
president we talked about this on the
show we'd have a different there would
be a different the the the the world
would look at us differently and that
would be and I'm not telling I'm not
telling you which way they'd look at us
differently but they would there would
be a difference and they'd say let's
listen to this guy he is the most
charismatic he seems like a good person
huh he's not I'll fight you I'll fight
you where the fight is happening I won't
talk about Jesus
Schwarzenegger is the greatest of all
time sorry the rock ain't
him okay Rock's up there Rock ain't him
yeah you're right about that you're
absolutely right about that but but the
arent one that was easy yes that was a
good one sure but not of all time I mean
there's still more time there's more
time there's more time for the rock for
The
Rock The Rock's got the Rock's got more
years the Arnold Schwarzenegger has more
years on the Rock than we do on your dad
when he got hit in the [__] rib with
a golf I agree but Schwarzenegger's
movies made more money he was more
famous he was the [__] Governor Rock
hasn't had a political office yet Rock
didn't do any of these things you know
why because Chad he's right yeah he's
right this is all time not the all time
that you don't even have yet the all of
time if time is you say this is all time
this is time that this happened come on
look at me I did everything I was the Mr
Olympia y then I was there uh the movie
star I did bought a bunch of real estate
you know in Southern California then I
moved to Northern California you know
why because that's where Sacramento is
that's where the capital is and because
I was the governor yeah and then now I'm
a social media influencer with two
donkeys ah I got two donkeys and I'm
always on the in the in the Instagram I
go shorts all right F wowe the second
ever dude's evening is in the books and
what a dude's evening it was you boys
racked up 100 points even which means
you have
8,077 total points and only need
1,933 more points before something very
special happens at 10,000 you both have
the New Year's off and our next episode
will be out on January 9th in that time
off I want you both to start the new
year with a clean bill of health by
going to get end of the year Callin
oscopies that's right you're both over
45 and you need to have cameras inserted
into your [__] by a stranger have
fun and now before we head into dudy
after dudy let's watch this astonishing
video made by some of the pods as a
dude's evening gift this is amazing this
is
incredible oh oh [__] dude
song
children
children's
we see when the the jingle
started it has been stuck in all of
their
heads that song was on
Halloween yeah I guess
[Music]
[__] have a chill evening at Thor's
disciple
and when you meet a stranger you'll
Shake
[Music]
hand look at the collection of things is
that an autograph will lemon that is I
signed a lemon for boar oh my God and
he's got the squirrel
skeleton he's got a dude's evening Stout
and a a dudy hard marijuana have a chill
dudes evening at
boar
[Music]
I move weight like you move your mouth
love that
shirt at Carolina Rock 28 have a CH D
evening CH
[Music]
evening oh got the head movement love it
good
dancing you can tell he's feeling I want
to shake
your necro
nice necro has set up yeah man make some
cool [__] on Instagram necro have a
chill D
[Music]
evening is amazing
Shake oh my
God record this four
times Tous d53 have a chill dudes
evening absolutely insane oh dude
[Music]
that's good
oh
UB have a chill dude's evening he writes
I'm so happy we made it to our second
dude's evening and that we're all
getting close to starting our third year
with oh he's a he's a good singer I
know he's made his own
qu that's
[Music]
awesome dude Johnny from
OK along with many others in this video
are contributing incredible stuff to our
amazing joh fromc have a chill dudes
evening absolutely incredible he says
will Chad and dudes the reason for the
season have a chill dudes evening
[Music]
nice
blue evening that's what it's all about
spending time with friends
insane ad ol blue have a chill D
[Music]
evening at
leash just a tad bit easier love you
darling humans plus dud thank you at
leer that's very sweet have a chill dud
evening some of the best people on
Discord on our
Discord I just can't believe that
they've all put together it it blew me
away at
payLo have a CH
evening it's all
[Music]
about on that day you want to know
something U Want know something
crazy that's Harris Dickinson that's
what a good actor he
is oh my God yeah
SI an
incredible 2 3 4 5 six different videos
no two of them are the
same no it's only two videos it's two
videos yeah I'm too stoned for this I'm
top top 14 Stone he's an incredible
rapper he's got Bars by the way check
him out as they say
a928 have a chill dudes
evening you are awesome in Despicable Me
spend time on that special day and when
you
strer where's he going he's in a car
he's doing this and then he's getting
out and walking in
somewhere A
ching have a chill dudes
evening a nice nighttime set up with
friends on that special
day when you meet a stranger shake their
hand
[Music]
say have a
chill seems like the
song's Dominique
Lavoy I love the hat on the headphones
absolutely love it it's a very nice
um he's balancing it unlike uh you when
we were watching
um a bigger better faster stronger
whatever
Wonka
atore isore
smelly delivering us some growling
well he's doing a Stone Cold Steve
Austin impression he's got the [__]
Stone Cold
Mas
beautiful great lights got like a Dy
logo in the light beautiful that me
Carl got hiso shirt
on it's all marijuana in hand I love
this thanks for the year of [__]
around Tronics of free will love you
guys the cream of the crop oh yeah the
cream of the crop yeah I am the cream of
the
[Music]
CR
mrus have a CH
z Oh and she's got a Dragon Ball Z
t-shirt on oh nice Dragon Ball Z
dude I'll never forget when you said
that we were watching that [__] thing
God there was some [__] you were saying
to there oh do be in your movie if I get
to drive of
Camaro I like this effect yeah this is
nice what with you pod have a CH evening
is wrong with
you andet Str shake the the shirt is
very dude's evening very festive
[Music]
yeah this is Cody howbert at Pals of
dudy no got the AL hat oh my God he's
got
the he's getting
drunker
oh oh oh well no one needs to see that
oh
[__] got a label over the crack yeah
we're oh that's a lot too much dudy
alcohol ah he had a night with the
dude's evening Stout we've all been
there yeah that looks like me after I uh
filled that Pringles can with puke oh
god
[Music]
dude there he is song
who put this
together so much incredible [__] on
consist and you meet a
Str shake
and wow oh my gosh
wow oh my
God
awesome absolutely
incredible wow thatal day and Str shake
and Peter Diaz hanging out of the you
and yours a CH that sounds exactly like
you that was [__] insane oh my god oh
maning thank you guys thanks to
everybody who who was a part of that and
uh I mean it really is mindblowing you
know to see uh so much effort to put
into something like that and we cannot
thank you enough and uh you know thanks
to everybody else who who joined us on
this ride too for this past year it's
been a fun one and I think next year
will be uh even more fun for sure dude
thank you guys thank you so much for
hanging out this was a this was for real
a chill dudes evening like I feel like
this is what a lot of the the you know
the pods P dudy out there are going to
be doing so hey man this was was this
was awesome [__] what a good that was
that was that was fun thanks to the pods
who put so much time and effort into
that astonishing video Masterpiece and
thanks to everyone who celebrated this
historic second dude's evening with us
we'll be back on January 9th have a
great New Year's Eve and again we'll see
everyone on January 9th you're not going
to want to miss it I promise I mean I
really promise that's all I should say
until then call me
dudy so we got we have to get uh
colonoscopies
[Music]
yeah yeah
yeah dude we got to do this oh
yeah hold
on we got to start
this hold on hold on a
second oh my God hold on dude
that's
so that's a baloney sand wo nice dude
see what I did yeah see what I did there
yeah welcome to dudy after dudy dudes
evening during dude's evening or
something like that because Chad and I
are really [__] stoned as a matter of
fact hey everybody Welcome to doy after
doy and uh let me tell you something
here at DW DZ after DW DZ on your fm
dial
10,000 uh uh uh the the what the [__]
were we just talking about how it's dudy
after dudy after dudes evening yeah it's
dudy after dudy during dudes evening
yeah
anyway just because we celebrated the
eight ways of dudes evening doesn't mean
the party ends we have a special dudes
evening dudy after dudy for you right
now it's the flagship weekly show of
dudy plus only at patreon.com dudy well
boys I'm I'm not sure how I'm going to
split these points up today but I have
to that's my literal job so I'm going to
go do the tabin while you boys get to
blabbin enjoy the rest of your dude's
evening together and I'll be back soon
to Crown the episode
Champion okay well I remember what I was
going to say yeah hey I just moved up
from 14 to 13 on how stoned I am oh nice
dude anyway uh have I told you yet what
my cat me and Laura's cat is now doing
no what he's see here's what you
do please tell a friend and R
review if you like to here what you
do please tell a friend then R
review if you like d what
you please tell a friend then